The Seijin no Hi or Coming of Age Day is an important public holiday in Japan.
Held on the second Monday of January, it celebrates reaching the ripe old age of 20,...
...considered to be the start of adulthood in Japan.
Parades are held, officials give speeches...
...and gifts are handed out to freshly minted grown-ups.
Most of the females coming of age wear "furisode,"...
...a formal style of kimono worn by unmarried women in Japan.
Turning 20 is a significant milestone because it's the minimum legal age...
...for voting, smoking and drinking in Japan.
While the day encourages young adults to accept their new responsibilities,...
...it only seems fair that they get to mark this rite of passage by partying into the night.